thank you
what is it like being the biggest media
star at the Super Bowl
I don't think I'm the biggest media star
some might disagree Mama Kelsey
all eyes were on Sons Travis and Jason
during the big game but once the clock
ran out their mama Donna she chatted
with E.T just days before kickoff for
all the stars to align and for this to
happen this is just like a dream come
true and the Kansas City Chiefs have won
Super Bowl 57. somebody's gonna win
somebody's gonna lose who do you go to
first I definitely want to go down and
celebrate with the person that's holding
the trophy about it Joe it's mama
Mama yep she made her way to try this
after the Kansas City Chiefs landed a
38-35 victory over the Philadelphia
Eagles his brother Jason's team I bought
it Joe
[Laughter]
how about this
we had the wig gear life I had the year
of my life how about this huh I just I
can't express enough how special this is
for the family and it's just crazy I
already saw the trail I'm looking for my
parents
I don't know if they're down here yet
give him a hug tell them I love them
there is nothing I can say that will
make him feel any better
and a sea of red and Golds and black and
greens Donna made sure her team spirit
was split down the middle so it's like
at the sleeves and then on the back
you know they have both their numbers on
it so it's kind of cool are they sitting
on my sideline
dude we do have to figure that out the
Kelsey siblings before a game day
together hosting a podcast New Heights
where there's plenty of Brotherly Love
to go around ever since I've been in the
league we went to Chances you know like
what do you feel if uh if you play your
brother in the Super One my entire time
I've been like I mean that's that's been
the goal listen I every parent says this
is the hardest question in the world
which one is your favorite you know each
one has been my favorite at certain
times in in their in their lives okay uh
right now Jason's a little ahead because
of the grandchildren but I'm sure Travis
will take it over soon so you know one
of these days but uh I I can't you you
know as a as a mother you just can't
pick one or against the other it's 50 50
and it always will be fast forward to
Super Bowl Sunday Donna made sure to
tell both boys they were winners
I love you
[Music]